那给大家选了生死狙击这部电影啊，为什么嘞？因为这是非常典型的男性爽片，符合过去美国比较传统的这种孤胆英雄式的大男性大爽片的模型啊。
当然了，现在咱们中国人呃新成长起来的中国小孩啊，也是爱看孤胆英雄。
呃，我们小时候没有这种国国产片，古胆英雄的比较少啊，大家还是爱看集体主义。呃，这部片子啊是非常典型的男平爽片，非常值得我们学习。商业片的本质实际是爽片，只不过有时候会进行一些艺术加工，搞一些这个修饰啊，我们来看来看一下生死狙击这部电影先看一下它的私募啊，私募节拍。
我们主要学习它的结构和它的方法论啊。
我们未必要啊完全赞同这种。
他们美式的这种孤胆英雄的这种体系啊，这个倒未必里面涉及的一些政治思考跟我们也没有什么关系啊。
第一拍第二分钟啊。
用了一个前十开场，给大家强调过，前十实际上不属于影片的私募范围内，前十是单拎出来的。
嗯，有时候前史是为了搞一个热开场，或者是充分展现一下主角的技能。第一拍，第二分钟也是一个前史的一个热开场的一个战争戏，讲的是主角和他以前的搭档啊执行一个狙击任务，然后被战略性放弃了队友牺牲。当然了也展示了他的技能展示了他的缺失，也就是说他眼看着队友牺牲了啊。
有一场很俗的戏，对吧？他那个队友还一个照片。
拿照片必死。然后呢当然当然了，这照片后面是有用的嘛，女女主后面出现了啊，同学们热开场开了6分钟，这不是网大嘛。
所以同学们为什么说它是个标准意义的大爽片是吧？爆米花大爽片？当然了比网大啊的品质还是要高一些啊，豆瓣评分接近8分7点大几。我曾经说啊，7点5到8点5之间是导演片最好的一个区间。第二拍第8分钟三年后啊三年后才正式进入故事的第一幕啊，从这里。
交代交代主角的环境啊，隐居山林。
嗯，由于他当年被战略性放弃，记着啊他当年是被战略性放弃的。所以说这部戏的前史是有用的啊，就是你又会被战略性放弃一次嘛。我们说这是主角的一个小龟壳啊，然后第三拍。
其实主要是那个黑人上司啊，后面为大家知道他是个反派，黑人上司出场，希望找到男主啊，通过他的嘴在增强男主的人设，说一下男主这个无敌的状态。但是大家看一下这场戏是什么视角啊，视角是用的一个轮椅男的一个过肩镜头。这个角色由于后面是一个隐藏人物，所以用他的视角交代啊，学导演的同学。
可以记一下，像这样的处理处理方式啊。第四拍啊，借着这个个黑人的一个上校吧，借着他的视角，他来访问我们我们的男主，想要邀请我们的男主去执行一个任务，各种激将法啊，软硬兼施，跟他套近乎。
扮演父亲。
第五拍16分钟，我们的男主拒绝了对方的邀请。但是。
嗯，这个黑人上司认为他已经答应了，只是他自己还不知道啊，弄得悬的活了。第六拍17分钟，嗯，我们的主角开始测试狙击狙击距离，他嘴上说不愿意去，但是他确实心动了啊，他已经开始开始测试，测试完之后决定上路啊，跟他的狗狗告别。
我们说这也是一个flag，因为狗死了。
第七排19分钟。
来到华盛顿以后啊，各种观察剧情做各种侦查工作啊，第八拍21分钟嗯，给出了专业的评估意见啊，任务进展的非常顺利而且潇洒啊，而且用了很多很仪式感的啊慢镜头。
戴墨镜呀，然后那个车队呀护送呀，整的反正整挺酷啊，整挺酷。
第九拍来了24分钟，任务当天啊，这个总统出来讲话呃，然后嘞呃伙伴。
后面的那个伙伴，大家都知道啊，那个男二后面的那个伙伴。
啊，那个南美裔的那个小伙啊登场。
胖警场也做了一个登场。那个胖警厂呢那个手手枪枪盒开着啊嗯暗示后面要有事儿发生，整个故事相当紧凑啊。第1盘来到28分钟，总统被袭击，实际杀的不是总统啊，是大主角。然后嘞我们的这个呃主角也被袭击受伤。然后第一幕结束啊。
故事来到第二幕第1一拍29分钟，我们的男主正式踏上了逃亡之路，对吧？喜被栽赃嘛，十二拍。
30分钟，我们说进入第二幕上路之后，第一件事情遇到伙伴嘛，所以十二拍，第二幕的第二个节拍，十二拍30分钟，男主和伙伴，也就是那个男二相遇啊，相遇夺枪夺车，夺了对方的枪和车1三拍还是30分钟啊，嗯开始游戏时间驱车躲藏呀。
在洗衣房里包扎自救呀，呃再次驾车逃逸呀、跳海呀，各种逃跑啊，各种逃跑。嗯，很多同学记得啊，我们说过呃，在很多电影里面他那个那个游戏时间都是追车洗，因为可以充分的展现男主的各种。
技能嘛，因为男主之前在他的山林环境里是展现不了这种技能的，他只有走出他的舒适区，踏上征程，才能展现他另外一面啊，这就是游戏时间的意义。
很多同学可能奇怪说游戏时间怎么是这么惨的一场戏是吧？所以网说有很多海外的教材确实翻译过来。
就不能问。
就不那么贴切嘛。
实际你可以理解的是什么呢？你想想看啊，我们一部戏游戏时间我经常说就是拍海报，你想想看。
我们说这个戏者故事讲的是啥？讲的是一个退役兵王。
被政府栽赃以后，逃亡和反击的故事。
他拥有他运用他的技术去躲藏，去跳海，去自己疗伤，这些就是我们最先预期到的画面，对吧？好。
来十四盘。
1四拍啊，37分钟嗯，男二也就是他的那个伙伴啊在FBI非常丢脸啊，被骂被排挤。15拍39分钟，男主呃买药啊自救躲藏16拍43分钟，男二那个伙伴得到男一的线索，但是还是没有人信他。
是吧他呢呃独自深入调查啊深入调查。
然后我们说这个从第二幕开始啊，这个伙伴戏份着实有点不少啊，这个伙伴其实称得上是男2呃，戏份极其多啊。
来。
17班来到45分钟，45分钟啊，男主投靠死去队友的前女友啊，我们说之前展示照片那个在这用上了啊，嗯投靠死去队友的前女友嗯，进行这个治伤啊，就治疗他的伤啊，很多同学可能奇怪啊，为什么突然出现了一个角色前女友啊一直。
嗯，不怎么好好穿衣服一直穿着内衣嗯，跟大家说一下啊，因为这个演员在这个呃这个演员出道啊，一直是走性感路线的啊呃他在指牌屋里面演员记者，大家不知道有没有印象啊，很多同学说为是这个有没有必要啊，其实有两个原因。第一个原因是呃这个演员本身就走这个路线啊。
呃，大众对他有这样的期待啊，就相当于你出来之后，你得兑现一下，对吧？这是第一点。第二点呢，我开篇就强调过啊，这个电影是是是一个男频爽片，毫无疑问的男屏爽片，好吧。
好，接着往下说啊。
第18拍49分钟，男二，也就是他那个伙伴啊发现了更多的破绽，持续调查了好几个回合啊，因为是平行切换啊，所以他持续调查了好几个回合，初步断定，这是个阴谋。我们说男二也有个女搭档啊。这个女演员在后面有一场戏里也是在家里接电话，然后穿着内衣。
因为这个女演员也以身材见长啊嗯。
他有部剧非常好看啊，借着这个演员，我看到这个演员想起来，有一部剧老的美剧你们可不知道听没听过，，现在有可能资源都不好找了，叫呃波士顿法律一部美剧很老的一部美剧啊，20多年前的哇，真的是演技巅峰啊，那个bostonleg的男主也演过黑名单啊。
好，我们接着说啊呃只是给大家说一下这样的男性爽片。他在选角的时候啊，选的确实是几几个女配角，确实是呃走性感路线的啊。相当于咱们的电影里面有两个呃西方不算太多的女性角色，是比如说是克拉拉和徐冬冬演的。
呃，跟花瓶没有关系啊，咱们不要说人家身材好，就是花瓶，不是这个意思啊，同样可以很有演技啊。1九拍啊来到52分钟呃，这个前女友啊给男主做手术，同时那个男二的那个调查线也平行推进啊平行推进，继续推进。
然后二十拍啊20拍59分钟啊，男主和女主的暧昧洗。
然后男主呢说服女主去诱惑男二入坑啊，诱惑男二入坑。同学们是是不是觉得这场暧昧戏其实挺没必要的？
你。
老搭档的未婚妻这个爱美戏有必要吗？在我们的文化里反正是觉得挺奇怪的对这有两点挺不舒服的。第一点呢，你们俩刚才还在那怀念是吧？那怀念着怀念着这这这怀念出激情的，这是很奇怪的一点啊，你这不不能这对吧？要不就别提嘛，这是第一。
第二点呢就是昨天刚近距离挨了两枪，今天就想那事儿，这啥替格子，那我咱还是觉得这场戏怪怪的，21盘来到64分钟啊，那个拿二的过程中啊呃遇到警察比划几下啊，获胜逃脱。
一个小插曲，22拍65分钟，男二继续深人挖啊，然后已经调查快接近真相了。但是呢被绑架被拷打啊，马上被杀。也就是说可以帮男一翻案的那个人。
几乎可以发案的那个人被杀了啊。
然后23拍故事进入第三幕，男主有个新的任务，因为第二幕男主是逃命啊，第二幕男主主要是逃命躲藏。从70分钟开始啊，23拍70分钟开始呢，男主开始要主动出击了啊。当然了，你也可以理解为男主派女主主动出击，就是进入第三步了，也没有问题啊，也没有问题。
这个区别不是很大，呃，主要是什么区别呢？第二幕是逃跑，第三步是报仇。
来。
男主把这个伙伴营救了之后呢，两个人决定合作啊，然后开始执行第二个任务，给狗报仇。
因为是这里提出来的嘛，第70分钟提出来给狗报仇，所以我给划在这儿了啊，同学们。
有的同学喜欢滑的往前一点也可以开始执行第二个任务啊，报仇。当然了，说给狗报仇也可以是一个比喻嘛，对吧？
2四拍72分钟。
我们说进入第三幕之后，反派又找到了女主的线索啊，新的威胁新的威胁诞生了，也给这个零魂液。
埋下一个伏笔，25拍来到73分钟，两个人去拜访了一位老前辈啊。
访问了一位高人是吧？类食神丢星的铁钳啊，都有这种桥段去拜访一高人啊，叫高人指点获取的重要信息。嗯，知道那个是谁杀的啊，是谁谁谁开的枪。26拍呢来到78分钟，反派的威胁持续的升级啊，这个黑人上校幕后还有更大的老板啊，有时也会有一个参议员。
涉及到更大身份的老板。
27拍来到80分钟啊呃又是一场女主的内衣戏份啊，遭到威胁，被坏人挟持。
28拍啊，来到81分钟，男主和这个男二啊进行一些站前准备，采购物资呀，包括训练呀。我们说这种这个戏放在这里其实是掉节奏的啊，因为女主被抓了，按道理应该是把灵魂黑业务这个情况往上推一推。这种戏啊一般来说是调节奏的，需要放在第二幕啊。
放在比较欢快的时刻，29开来到83分钟。
坏人折磨女主啊，各种折磨。
30拍84分钟啊，男一男二攻击杀手的这个老巢啊获胜了啊，而且那个杀手自杀了，但是获取了也获取了很多重要的信息。，但是对手的部队呢已经包围过来了。
31盘啊91分钟嗯，双方战斗啊呃集结过来部队嘛，主角方胜利的逃脱了啊，胜利的逃脱32盘96分钟，敌方啊继续升级手段啊，这个高层比比那个呃黑人上棋更新奋手了。
然后33拍98分钟，男主和敌方通电话啊呃相约见面交换人质和条件。我们说因为进入第四步了嘛，最后的这个这个解决方案交换人质。
34拍啊雪山点啊约见。我们说这一场的场面辨识度非常高，在雪山底进行了一个呃约见交换交换交换交换条件啊，然后一场狙击战斗戏，因为我们的主角是狙击狙击手出身。我们这个戏的名字也叫ser，所以说他只能用狙击的方式来解决问题。当然了，用狙击的方式解决问题。
场面就不太好看，对不对？同学们能理解吧？回忆一下，因为我们的主角是狙击手，他不像发哥，对吧？可以两手拿着冲锋枪。
就很帅，对吧？他就不好弄，所以说这里也确实是嗯打了很多嘴炮啊，在正常最重要的大决斗戏里面打了很多嘴炮啊，然后呢也也算是有勇有谋吧，用用各种计谋啊，各种计谋配合这个配合这个狙击。
然后35拍啊，110分钟有一场内部审问戏啊，内部审问戏呃，不是法庭啊，他再次用自己的智慧啊和反转证证明了自己的清白。
但是呢由于反派有豁免权啊，根本不会受到惩罚。我们说这个戏到这里私募就结束了，然后最后再给个彩蛋，你不是不惩罚吗？我惩罚啊，我们的主角啊再次主持正义36拍啊，我们的主角再次主持正义，杀掉了所有的反派。好，这是整个戏的一个脉络啊，由于是1个7点几分的伤害片。
脉络非常清晰啊脉络非常清晰，主角的行动线呢也一直非常的明确。我们说这个主角一直是前面是。
接受一个任务惹事了。然后第二幕真正的目标就是开始逃跑。然后到故事终点以后呢，开始反击，对吧？我们说反击，然后呢又用了计谋，又用了勇气反击了，也是呃123三个批次，对吧？第一个批次杀掉那个杀手。第二个批次呢，雪山顶。
跟。
幕后boss啊硬刚，然后第最后呢又呃靠自己把所有人都杀掉啊，有一个三拍的一个动作啊，同学们。
男性爽片。
这部片子里面有多少爽片元素？最近很多同学正在研究短剧啊，借着这部片子来，你们跟我说一下，男性爽片里面都有哪些常规元素，我说一下啊。
首先，兵王他是一个枪神，这是南剑爽片的很重要的元素吧。男生都喜欢的啊，我是个兵王，我是战神第一。
第二是车。
各种各样的车，各种各样的追车对吧？
然后第三，狗，第四，露营或者叫隐居。
露营隐居也是男性的大爽脸啊。
他如果在钓鱼，那就更爽了啊。他如果带着狗在河边钓鱼，那就更爽了。然后当然了，性感女神也是重要元素，讲义起有没有同学们。
很多爽片是以照顾战友的遗孀或者是妹妹或者是女儿为开头的。
讲义气，男人都意淫，自己讲义气，男凭爽片嘛，就是男性的意淫，然后啊装备展示。
我跟大家讲过啊，各种眼花缭乱的装备展示爽不爽，爽，对装备了如指掌，对吧？
知道哪儿是哪儿技术啊一摸，我就知道这个枪神医剧神医剧就是这种爽点。同学们啊，就一个人的技术出神入化，神医剧神医剧啊。
就是这种双脚。
装备展时。
了如指掌，还有什么爽点元素啊，高人指点。我说为什么你看那些南平大闯去经常是上山去拜访一个高人高人指点。
平常就一淫自己希望得到高人的指点。
然后还有什么？
带小弟带徒弟。我们说这种上帝视角的爽感，我能感改变别人，我能训练别人。他本来是一个。
但散对吧？我点化他一下之后，他可以成为英雄。
带小弟。
也是男人的大双店呀。然后还有。
阴谋论。
阴谋论也是也是这种你像爽点，就比我强的人肯定不是好人，他们肯定就那些再高高在上的人没好东西，对吧？阴谋论也是个大双点。
高高在上的人肯定是坏人是吧？为什么这个这个大家都喜欢看牛逼的人翻车呃，塌防被抓，嗯他们肯定不是好人，他们比我有本事，理气的因为他们不是好人。另外呢你更体制的对抗，伸张正义，那肯定是这部片子最重要的大手标啊，对抗强权，然后伸张正义。所以。
同学们可以通过这部片子，把这些男性爽点记一记啊。你在写男男频视角的爽片的时候，这些都能用得上，别太少爽点啊。我们说男屏我在短剧课上给大家讲过啊，男屏和女频的爽点要分清。但是呢男频爽点你可以给多种。
给多种未必只局限于一种打脸啊。有同学问第四幕在哪分？第四幕在那个灵魂黑所谓的女主，对吧？前女友给抓走了吗？
第四步就是大家要交换人质嘛，最后一个解决方案不是雪山顶见交换人质吗？
所以说第四幕是你可以理解为，因为这个事好像是双方里打电话沟通的对吧？第四幕是最后一个解决方案。另外啊对，有同学问这个灵魂黑夜啊，这部戏的灵魂黑夜确实发生在女配角身上啊，就是他被抓了，为什么嘞？因为你理解一下啊，这个女生。
不管有没有跟我们的男主发生那场暧昧戏，他都是男主的因果啊。
他都是男主的因果嘛。所以说在这部戏当中，如果说有那么一刻最让我们揪心，那肯定是这个女孩被抓了嘛，而且疑似被凌辱了，对不对？
都没怎么穿衣服，然后身上全是伤，那那肯定是。
因为这才是让我们最揪心的那一时刻吧。因为这个女主算是男主外化出来的缺陷嘛。这个理解吧，我在短剧课上讲过啊，由于现在比较流行这种战狼题材啊，男屏的这些都是极度爽片的话，这个男主一般来说没有缺陷，打都打不死，对吧？他没有缺陷就没有危机嘛。
我们就不揪心嘛，那只能外化出来一个女的让人抓。那你本身没缺陷，那你咋整啊？那我还咋咋对付你呀？
打也打不死，你也没啥缺陷，智慧还比我高。你让我反派咋整，还咋看嘛？这电影另外这部戏还得搞一个知识点啊，还得看一个东西啊，就是关于这个男二啊。
同学们有没有感觉这个男儿有点多余或者细风很多啊，他何德何能成为我们的男主的搭档呢？小菜鸟一个问题出在哪儿？狙击是三两天能学会的事儿吗？而且他上来。
第一次跟男主见面就非常的菜鸡，对吧？然后被男主嘘嘘嘘很顺利的抢了枪，抢了车。不是为什么这个这个戏份这么多呢？首先说一下啊，这个男主这个男尔还是很有用的。
因为我们的男主。
最大的伤痛，最大的曲那个女孩是她外化出来局限线，是她的因果。她为什么要有这个因果？她为什么要有这个因果？
那不就还是搭档那件事嘛？是确实是需要他再获得一个搭档，以弥补他内心的缺陷。这是是是我说的动机问题啊。就创作者为什么要饰演一个搭档，他本来有一个这样的角色嘛，但是我们为什么没有感受到创作者的这种好意呢？同学们本意识好，是因为我告诉大家原因。
是因为他不够帅。
你们现在闭上眼睛。
脑补一下哎演，我们说假设。
我们的男主是目前是这个马特沃尔伯格，比如说我们给他换成一个就换成马特达门好了，或者你换一个你觉得比较帅的，比较像书生的一个人，你脑补一下。
这个FBI。
顶着巨大的压力，对抗上司，调查出了靠一己之力，调查出了整个事情所有的来龙去脉。你还会觉得他是个菜鸡吗？不会吧，所以还是吃亏在长相。我没有说加强他的戏份，同学们，如果换一个帅的演员，他现在的戏份不用动。
都很合理。
问题不是出在戏上。
不是出在创作上，是这个演员不帅呀。
或者是没有魅力，对吧？长得不像一个特别有智慧的人，因为这个角色跟我们的男主的互补法显然是什么？一个文官，一个武官嘛。当然了，演员是个很好的演员，也演过很多好的戏，演过大的美剧啊，年度收视冠军的那个美剧，什么大毒枭的那个美剧。
也演过很多电影，演员肯定是个好演员。我们来进到最后啊进到最后关于这类电影的写法，我们说这种孤胆英雄类的角色啊，孤胆英雄类的角色嗯，同类的参考影片还有深渊人啊。嗯大家去看一下深渊人也是这种类型。首先。
啊，是一个隐食啊，是一个隐居的高手。我们说这种角色都是这样开场的啊，一个隐居的高手。
当然了，你可以前面拍一个前十，他之前是如何受委屈的一个隐居的高手，但是隐居的高手依然有人去惹他。
欺人太甚是吧？把他从。
原本的舒适区里面逼出来，他要出手了。
出手之后，那当然是一路开挂呀。
但是呢软肋被攻击，那最后咋解决问题呢？必须是智慧配合武力。我们说这类爽片都是这种路径了啊，那关于这类片子的爽点，我刚才也都讲过了，有同学说有部电影帮狗复仇。对啊，急速追杀嘛，也可以去看一下深渊人好吧，学一下这类大爽片的写法。
啊，说不定用得上吧，那目前嗯还是比较流行大爽片的啊，比较流行大爽片。